TODD KERPELMAN: Hello, there.
I'm Todd Kerpelman for
the Developer Show,
and this is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
A few weeks ago at Google I/O,
we released a major update
to AR core, Google's augmented
reality development platform.
We built some
experiences to showcase
how the new API
has come to life,
including this totally fun
multiplayer game that I played,
and they are now open-sourced.
So to see these
experiences in action,
get some insights from
behind the scenes,
and find links to
the GitHub repos,
head on over to the
post in the link below.
The latest What's
New in Chrome is out,
highlighting everything
new in Chrome 67.
Check out the post and
video to learn more
about desktop Progressive
Web Apps, the Generic Sensor
API, and BigInts.
Oh, I like BigInts,
and I cannot lie.
As you may have
heard, on May 25,
a new piece of European
legislation came into force--
the General Data Protection
Regulation, or GDPR,
as the cool kids
like to call it.
The Firebase team
has been working hard
over the past few
months to help ensure
that you have the
resources you need
to comply with
these regulations,
including new
GDPR-friendly terms, a way
to specify a data processing
officer or EU representative
in the Firebase console, as
well as new doxxing guides.
Check out the post for
screenshots and links
to everything.
Also, you now have another email
from some company about how
they've updated
their privacy policy,
and maybe you should read it.
Data Studio is Google's next gen
business intelligence and data
visualization platform,
and community connections
for Data Studio let
you build connectors
to internet-accessible data
sources using Google Apps
Script, which means
that you can view data
from many different sources
in one convenient report.
Check out the post
for some more detail
as well as a link to the new
Community Connector code lab
so you can get started today.
As part of our constant
efforts to improve
Google's OAuth
application ecosystem,
we're launching
additional protections
that can limit the spread
of malicious applications.
Apps requiring OAuth
will be subject
to a daily total new user cap
and a new user acquisition rate
limit, although these
rates will initially
be set to something close
to your app's current usage.
So the impact for most of
you should be pretty minimal.
But for more details and a link
to request a rate limit quota
increase, head on
over to the post.
So there you have it.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Todd Kerpelman for
the Developer Show.
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
Crazy 2's-- 1, 2, 1, 2,
1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 1, 1, 1.
Oh, I kicked something.
Sorry.
[LAUGHTER]